tenemos aquí dos ejemplos en los que una
persona intento encontrar una derivada
del lado izquierdo dice que abril
intento encontrar la derivada de 7 menos
5x usando propiedades básicas de las
derivadas y este es su trabajo y del
lado derecho dice que anna intentó
encontrar la derivada de menos 3 más 8 x
usando propiedades básicas de las
derivadas y este es su trabajo entonces
aquí tenemos dos ejercicios de derivadas
que puedes encontrar en la página de
khan academy y bueno los puse uno al
lado de otro para que podamos ver y
comparar qué cosas hacen bien y qué
cosas hacen mal cada una de estas
personas
estamos encontrando la derivada de
expresiones muy parecidas en ambos casos
tenemos una constante y un término de
primer grado aquí también tenemos una
constante y un término de primer grado y
aquí tenemos todos los pasos que
siguieron para encontrar la derivada
pero bueno vamos a empezar con abril
con el primer paso está sacando la
derivada de 7 menos 5x y en el primer
paso lo que hace es sumar la derivada de
estos dos x aquí está sacando la
derivada de 7 y luego por aquí tenemos
que poner mucha atención porque aquí
está sacando la derivada de 5x por aquí
mi instinto ninja está diciéndome eviten
cuidado que es lo que le pasó a este
signo menos por acá sacando esta
derivada tiene sentido que ponga la
derivada con respecto de x de 7 y luego
tiene que poner un signo menos y la
derivada con respecto de x de 5x esta es
una de las posibilidades pero no es la
única también pudo haber puesto la
derivada con respecto de x de 7 nosotros
ya vimos que una de las propiedades
básicas es que la derivada de una resta
es la resta de las derivadas
esta no es la única forma de sacar una
derivada también pudo haberlo hecho de
esta otra forma poniendo la derivada con
respecto de x de 7 más la derivada con
respecto de x de menos 5x ambas
expresiones son equivalentes a esta pero
esta expresión que puso abril no es
equivalente a estas porque se le olvidó
el signo menos así es que yo digo que
tuvo un problema en el paso 1 pero bueno
vamos a seguir viendo todo lo que hizo
abril en los siguientes pasos para ver
si ese fue el único error o hubo más por
aquí saco la derivada de esta constante
y las constantes no cambian conforme
cambia la x así es que en efecto la
derivada con respecto de x de 7 si es 0
por acá seguimos teniendo el mismo
término la derivada con respecto de x de
5x pero hay mucho ojo aquí es donde se
nos olvidó el signo menos por aquí este
signo menos se nos olvidó en este paso
así es que por aquí también
y ha de llevar un signo menos podría ser
la derivada con respecto de x de menos
5x o también lo podríamos tener como
menos la derivada con respecto de x de
5x y ahora veamos qué hace en el paso 3
este 0 desaparece y aquí lo que hace es
tomar la constante y sacarla porque la
derivada de una constante por algo
sabemos que es exactamente igual a esa
constante por la derivada de ese algo y
luego vamos para abajo abril encuentra
que está derivada es igual a 1 lo cual
también es cierto si dibujáramos la
gráfica de esta función si dibujáramos
igual a x podríamos ver que la pendiente
es 1 aquí nos estamos preguntando cuál
es la tasa de cambio de cuánto cambia x
con respecto a cuánto cambia x y eso
pues siempre va a ser igual a 1 porque
hay la pendiente aquí es igual a 1 y
entonces nos queda 5 x 1 que es
y por acá nos preguntan que si hubo un
error en este procedimiento en donde se
equivocó abril pero nosotros sabemos que
abril se equivocó en el paso 1 por aquí
esto debió haber sido un menos y si esto
hubiera sido un menos aquí tendríamos un
menos aquí también tendríamos un menos y
luego aquí deberíamos de tener un menos
y la respuesta final debió haber sido
menos 5 pero bueno ahora vamos con este
ejercicio vamos a ver cómo lo resolvió
anna vamos a ver si se equivocó en algún
lugar y en este caso en donde se
equivocó anna está derivando una
expresión bastante parecida primero toma
la derivada de la constante y le suma la
derivada del término de primer grado la
derivada del término constante es cero
eso está muy bien por aquí tenemos este
cero que va a desaparecer y tenemos este
término ahora lo único que tiene que
hacer ana es encontrar este término
veamos cómo lo hace
esto no se ve muy bien por aquí
anna está suponiendo que la derivada de
una multiplicación de dos términos es la
multiplicación de las derivadas de esos
términos pero eso no es cierto pero
además como aquí tenemos una constante
esta es la constante hay una forma mucho
más fácil de resolver esta derivada que
es hacerlo como lo hizo abril solo que
abril se equivocó primero en el paso 1
la derivada de una constante por un
término es igual a la constante por la
derivada de esa expresión esta es la
forma correcta de sacar esta derivada y
luego por aquí la derivada de x con
respecto a x esto es 1 por lo que esto
se simplifica en un 8 y listo pero lo
que hizo ana fue otra cosa
anna más bien tomó la multiplicación de
las derivadas tomó la derivada de 8 y la
multiplicó por la derivada de x pero así
no es la deriva
de una multiplicación más adelante vamos
a ver la regla del producto que si nos
dice cómo se hace para sacar la derivada
de la multiplicación de algunos términos
pero por el momento no necesitas aplicar
la regla de los productos porque uno de
estos términos es una constante pero
bueno el punto es que ana se equivocó en
este paso aquí y como podemos ver ana en
lugar de obtener la respuesta correcta 8
obtiene 0 porque aquí está sacando la
derivada de 8 que es 0 y luego saca la
derivada de x que es 100 por uno es cero
así es que termina con cero que no es la
respuesta correcta así es que abril
cometió un error en el paso 1 y anna
cometió un error en el paso 3